ANNOUNCER: Open content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu .
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
Good morning.
We should start with the
confession, for those of you
looking at this on
OpenCourseWare, that I'm
currently lecturing to
an empty auditorium.
The fifth lecture for 600 this
term, we ran into some
technical difficulties, which
left us with a recording we
weren't very satisfied with.
So, I'm-- this is a redo, and if
you will hear no questions
from the audience and that's
because there is no audience.
Nevertheless I will do
my best to pretend.
I've been told this is a little
bit like giving a
speech before the US Congress
when C-SPAN is
the only thing watching.
OK.
Computers are supposed to be
good for crunching numbers.
And we've looked a little bit
at numbers this term, but I
now want to get into looking
at them in more depth than
we've been doing.
Python has two different
kinds of numbers.
So far, the only kind we've
really paid any attention to
is type int.
And those were intended to
mirror the integers, as we all
learned about starting
in elementary school.
And they're good for things
that you can count.
Any place you'd use
whole numbers.
Interestingly, Python, unlike
some languages, has what are
called arbitrary precision
integers.
By that, we mean, you can
make numbers as big as
you want them to.
Let's look at an example.
We'll just take a for a variable
name, and we'll set a
to be two raised to the
one-thousandth power.
That, by the way, is a
really big number.
And now what happens if
we try and display it?
We get a lot of digits.
You can see why I'm doing this
on the screen instead of
writing it on the blackboard.
I'm not going to ask you whether
you believe this is
the right answer, trust
me, trust Python.
I would like you to notice, at
the very end of this is the
letter L.
What does that mean?
It means long.
That's telling us that it's
representing these-- this
particular integer in
what it calls it's
internal long format.
You needn't worry about that.
The only thing to say about it
is, when you're dealing with
long integers, it's a lot less
efficient than when you're
dealing with smaller numbers.
And that's all it's kind of
warning you, by printing this
L.
About two billion is
the magic number.
When you get over two billion,
it's now going to deal with
long integers, so if, for
example, you're trying to deal
with the US budget deficit, you
will need integers of type
L.
OK.
Let's look at another
interesting example.
Suppose I said, b equal to two
raised to the nine hundred
ninety-ninth power.
I can display b, and it's a
different number, considerably
smaller, but again,
ending in an L.
And now, what you think I'll get
if we try a divided by b?
And remember, we're now doing
integer division.
Well, let's see.
We get 2L.
Well, you'd expect it to be
two, because if you think
about the meaning of
exponentiation, indeed, the
difference between raising
something to the nine hundred
ninety-ninth power and to the
one-thousandth power should
be, in this case, two, since
that's what we're
raising to a power.
Why does it say 2L, right?
Two is considerably less than
two billion, and that's
because once you get L, you
stay L. Not particularly
important, but kind
of worth knowing.
Well, why am I bothering you
with this whole issue of how
numbers are represented
in the computer?
In an ideal world, you would
ignore this completely, and
just say, numbers do what
numbers are supposed to do.
But as we're about to see,
sometimes in Python, and in
fact in every programming
language, things behave
contrary to what your
intuition suggests.
And I want to spend a little
time helping you understand
why this happens.
So let's look at a different
kind of number.
And now we're going to look at
what Python, and almost every
other programming language,
calls type float.
Which is short for
floating point.
And that's the way that
programming languages
typically represent what we
think of as real numbers.
So, let's look at an example.
I'm going to set the variable
x to be 0.1, 1/10, and now
we're going to display x.
Huh?
Take a look at this.
Why isn't it .1?
Why is it 0.1, a whole bunch
of zeros, and then this
mysterious one appearing
at the end?
Is it because Python just wants
to be obnoxious and is
making life hard?
No, it has to do with the way
the numbers are represented
inside the computer.
Python, like almost every modern
programming language,
represents numbers using the
i triple e floating point
standard, and it's
i triple e 754.
Never again will you have to
remember that it's 754.
I promise not to ask you that
question on a quiz.
But that's what they do.
This is a variant of scientific
notation.
Something you probably learned
about in high school, as a way
to represent very
large numbers.
Typically, the way we do that,
is we represent the numbers in
the form of a mantissa
and an exponent.
So we represent a floating point
number as a pair, of a
mantissa and an exponent.
And because computers work in
the binary system, it's unlike
what you probably learned in
high school, where we raise
ten to some power.
Here we'll always be raising
two to some power.
Maybe a little later in the
term, if we talk about
computer architecture, we'll get
around to explaining why
computers working binary, but
for now, just assume that they
do and in fact they
always have. All right.
Purists manage to refer to the
mantissa as a significant, but
I won't do that, because I'm
an old guy and it was a
mantissa when I first learned
about it and I just can't
break myself of the habit.
All right.
So how does this work?
Well, when we recognize so--
when we represent something,
the mantissa is between
one and two.
Whoops.
Strictly less than two, greater
than or equal to one.
The exponent, is in the
range, -1022 to +1023.
So this lets us represent
numbers up to about 10 to the
308th, plus or minus 10 to
the 308th, plus or minus.
So, quite a large range
of numbers.
Where did these magic
things come from?
You know, what-- kind of a
strange numbers to see here.
Well, it has to do with the fact
that computers typically
have words in them, and the
words today in a modern
computer are 64 bits.
For many years they were 32
bits, before that they were 16
bits, before that they were 8
bits, they've continually
grown, but we've been at 64 for
a while and I think we'll
be stuck at 64 for a while.
So as we do this, what we do
is, we get one bit for the
sign-- is it a positive
or negative number?--
11 for the exponent, and that
leaves 52 for the mantissa.
And that basically tells us
how we're storing numbers.
Hi, are you here for
the 600 lecture?
There is none today, because we
have a quiz this evening.
It's now the time that the
lecture would normally have
started, and a couple of
students who forgot that we
have a quiz this evening,
instead of a lecture, just
strolled in, and now
strolled out.
OK.
You may never need to know these
constants again, but
it's worth knowing that they
exist, and that basically,
this gives us about the
equivalent of seventeen
decimal digits of precision.
So we can represent numbers
up to seventeen
decimal digits long.
This is an important concept to
understand, that unlike the
long ints where they can grow
arbitrarily big, when we're
dealing with floating points, if
we need something more than
seventeen decimal digits, in
Python at least, we won't be
able to get it.
And that's true in
many languages.
Now the good news is, this is
an enormous number, and it's
highly unlikely that ever in
your life, you will need more
precision than that.
All right.
Now, let's go back to the 0.1
mystery that we started at,
and ask ourselves, why we have
a problem representing that
number in the computer, hence,
we get something funny out
from we try and print it back.
Well, let's look at an easier
problem first. Let's look at
representing the fraction 1/8.
That has a nice representation.
That's equal in decimal to
0.125, and we can represent it
conveniently in both
base 10 and base 2.
So if you want to represent
it in base 10, what is it?
What is that equal to?
Well, we'll take a mantissa,
1.25, and now we need to
multiply it by something that
we can represent nicely, and
in fact that will be
times 10 to the -1.
So the exponent would simply
be -1, and we have a nice
representation.
Suppose we want to represent
it in base 2?
What would it be?
1.0 times-- anybody?--
Well, 2 to the -3.
So, in binary notation, that
would be written as 0.001.
So you see, 1/8 is kind
of a nice number.
We can represent it nicely in
either base 10 or base 2.
But how about that pesky
fraction 1/10?
Well, in base 10, we know
how to represent, it's
1 times 10 to the--
10 to the what?--
10 to the 1?
No.
But in base 2, it's a problem.
There is no finite binary number
that exactly represents
this decimal fraction.
In fact, if we try and find
the binary number, what we
find is, we get an infinitely
repeating series.
Zero zero zero one one zero
zero one one zero
zero, and et cetera.
Stop at any finite number of
bits, and you get only an
approximation to the decimal
fraction 1/10.
So on most computers, if you
were to print the decimal
value of the binary
approximation-- and that's
what we're printing here,
on this screen, right?
We think in decimal, so Python
quite nicely for us is
printing things in decimal--
it would have to display--
well I'm not going to write it,
it's a very long number,
lots of digits-- however, in
Python, whenever we display
something, it uses the built-in
function repr, short
for representation, that it
converts the internal
representation in this case of
a number, to a string, and
then displays that string in
this case on the screen.
For floats, it rounds it
to seventeen digits.
There's that magic number
seventeen again.
Hence, when it rounds it to
seventeen digits, we get
exactly what you see in the
bottom of the screen up there.
Answer to the mystery, why
does it display this?
Now why should we care?
Well, it's not so much that
we care about what gets
displayed, but we have to think
about the implications,
at least sometimes we have to
think about the implications,
of what this inexact
representation of numbers
means when we start doing
more-or-less complex
computations on those numbers.
So let's look at a little
example here.
I'll start by starting the
variable s to 0.0 .
Notice I'm being careful
to make it a float.
And then for i in range, let's
see, let's take 10, we'll
increase s by 0.1 .
All right, we've done that,
and now, what happens
when I print s?
Well, again you don't get
what your intuition
says you should get.
Notice the last two digits,
which are eight and nine.
Well, what's happening here?
What's happened, is the
error has accumulated.
I had a small error when I
started, but every time I
added it, the error got bigger
and it accumulates.
Sometimes you can get in trouble
in a computation
because of that.
Now what happens, by the
way, if I print s?
That's kind of an interesting
question.
Notice that it prints one.
And why is that?
It's because the print command
has done a rounding here.
It automatically rounds.
And that's kind of good, but
it's also kind of bad, because
that means when you're debugging
your program, you
can get very confused.
You say, it says it's one, why
am I getting a different
answer when I do the
computation?
And that's because it's
not really one inside.
So you have to be careful.
Now mostly, these round-off
errors balance each other out.
Some floats are slightly higher
than they're supposed
to be, some are slightly
lower, and in most
computations it all comes out
in the wash and you get the
right answer.
Truth be told, most of the time,
you can avoid worrying
about these things.
But, as we say in Latin,
caveat computor.
Sometimes you have to
worry a little bit.
Now there is one thing about
floating points about which
you should always worry.
And that's really the point I
want to drive home, and that's
about the meaning
of double equal.
Let's look at an example
of this.
So we've before seen the use
of import, so I'm going to
import math, it gives me some
useful mathematical functions,
then I'm going to set the
variable a to the
square root of two.
Whoops.
Why didn't this work?
Because what I should have
said is math dot
square root of two.
Explaining to the interpreter
that I want to get the
function sqrt from
the module math.
So now I've got a here, and I
can look at what a is, yeah,
some approximation to the square
root about of two.
Now here's the interesting
question.
Suppose I ask about the Boolean
a times a equals
equals two.
Now in my heart, I think, if
I've taken the square root of
number and then I've multiplied
it by itself, I
could get the original
number back.
After all, that's the meaning
of square root.
But by now, you won't be
surprised if the answer of
this is false, because we know
what we've stored is only an
approximation to the
square root.
And that's kind of
interesting.
So we can see that, by, if I
look at a times a, I'll get
two point a whole bunch
of zeros and then
a four at the end.
So this means, if I've got a
test in my program, in some
sense it will give me the
unexpected answer false.
What this tells us, is that it's
very risky to ever use
the built-in double--equals to
compare floating points, and
in fact, you should never be
testing for equality, you
should always be testing
for close enough.
So typically, what you want to
do in your program, is ask the
following question: is the
absolute value of a times a
minus 2.0 less than epsilon?
If we could easily type Greek,
we'd have written it that way,
but we can't.
So that's some small value
chosen to be appropriate for
the application.
Saying, if these two things
are within epsilon of each
other, then I'm going to
treat them as equal.
And so what I typically do when
I'm writing a Python code
that's going to deal with
floating point numbers, and I
do this from time to time, is I
introduce a function called
almost equal, or near, or pick
your favorite word, that does
this for me.
And wherever I would normally
written double x equals y,
instead I write, near x,y, and
it computes it for me.
Not a big deal, but keep this
in mind, or as soon as you
start dealing with numbers, you
will get very frustrated
in trying to understand what
your program does.
OK.
Enough of numbers for a while,
I'm sure some of you will find
this a relief.
I now want to get away from
details of floating point, and
talk about general methods
again, returning to the real
theme of the course of solving
problems using computers.
Last week, we looked at the
rather silly problem of
finding the square root
of a perfect square.
Well, that's not usually
what you need.
Let's think about the more
useful problem of finding the
square root of a real number.
Well, you've just seen
how you do that.
You import math and
you call sqrt.
Let's pretend that we didn't
know that trick, or let's
pretend it's your job to
introduce-- implement,
rather-- math.
And so, you need to figure out
how to implement square root.
Why might this be a challenge?
What are some of the issues?
And there are several.
One is, what we've just seen
might not be an exact answer.
For example, the square
root of two.
So we need to worry about that,
and clearly the way
we're going to solve that, as
we'll see, is using a concept
similar to epsilon.
In fact, we'll even
call it epsilon.
Another problem with the method
we looked at last time
is, there we were doing
exhaustive enumeration.
We were enumerating all the
possible answers, checking
each one, and if it was
good, stopping.
Well, the problem with reals, as
opposed to integers, is we
can't enumerate all guesses.
And that's because the reals
are uncountable.
If I ask you to enumerate the
positive integers, you'll say
one, two, three, four, five.
If I ask you to enumerate the
reals, the positive reals,
where do you start?
One over a billion,
plus who knows?
Now as we've just seen in fact,
since there's a limit to
the precision floating point,
technically you can enumerate
all the floating
point numbers.
And I say technically, because
if you tried to do that, your
computation would not terminate
any time soon.
So even though in some, in
principle you could enumerate
them, in fact you
really can't.
And so we think of the floating
points, like the
reals, as being innumerable.
Or not innumerable, as to say
as being uncountable.
So we can't do that.
So we have to find something
clever, because we're now
searching a very large space
of possible answers.
What would, technically
you might call
a large state space.
So we're going to take our
previous method of guess and
check, and replace it by
something called guess, check,
and improve.
Previously, we just generated
guesses in some systematic
way, but without knowing
that we were getting
closer to the answer.
Think of the original barnyard
problem with the chickens and
the heads and the legs, we just
enumerated possibilities,
but we didn't know that one
guess was better than the
previous guess.
Now, we're going to find a way
to do the enumeration where we
have good reason to believe,
at least with high
probability, that each
guess is better than
the previous guess.
This is what's called successive
approximation.
And that's a very important
concept.
Many problems are solved
computationally using
successive approximation.
Every successive approximation
method has
the same rough structure.
You start with some guess, which
would be the initial
guess, you then iterate-- and in
a minute I'll tell you why
I'm doing it this particular
way, over some range.
I've chosen one hundred, but
doesn't have to be one
hundred, just some number
there-- if f of x, that is to
say some some function of my--
Whoops, I shouldn't
have said x.
My notes say x, but it's the
wrong thing-- if f of x, f of
the guess, is close enough, so
for example, if when I square
guess, I get close enough to
the number who's root I'm--
square root I'm looking for,
then I'll return the guess.
If it's not close enough,
I'll get a better guess.
If I do my, in this case, one
hundred iterations, and I've
not get-- gotten a guess that's
good enough, I'm going
to quit with some error.
Saying, wow.
I thought my method was good
enough that a hundred guesses
should've gotten me there.
If it didn't, I may be wrong.
I always like to have some
limit, so that my program
can't spin off into the ether,
guessing forever.
OK.
Let's look at an example
of that.
So here's a successive
approximation
to the square root.
I've called it square root bi.
The bi is not a reference to the
sexual preferences of the
function, but a reference to
the fact that this is an
example of what's called
a bi-section method.
The basic idea behind any
bi-section method is the same,
and we'll see lots of examples
of this semester, is that you
have some linearly-arranged
space of possible answers.
And it has the property that if
I take a guess somewhere,
let's say there, I guess that's
the answer to the
question, if it turns out that's
not the answer, I can
easily determine whether the
answer lies to the left or the
right of the guess.
So if I guess that 89.12 is the
square root of a number,
and it turns out not to be the
square root of the number, I
have a way of saying, is 89.12
too big or too small.
If it was too big, then I
know I'd better guess
some number over here.
It was too small, then
I'd better guess
some number over here.
Why do I call it bi-section?
Because I'm dividing it in half,
and in general as we'll
see, when I know what my space
of answers is, I always, as my
next guess, choose something
half-way along that line.
So I made a guess, and let's say
was too small, and I know
the answer is between here and
here, this was too small, I
now know that the answer is
between here and here, so my
next guess will be
in the middle.
The beauty of always guessing
in the middle is, at each
guess, if it's wrong, I
get to throw out half
of the state space.
So I know how long it's going
to take me to search the
possibilities in some sense,
because I'm getting
logarithmically progressed.
This is exactly what we saw when
we looked at recursion in
some sense, where we solved the
problem by, at each step,
solving a smaller problem.
The same problem, but on a
smaller solution space.
Now as it happens, I'm not
using recursion in this
implementation we have up on
the screen, I'm doing it
iteratively but the
idea is the same.
So we'll take a quick look at
it now, then we'll quit and
we'll come back to in the next
lecture a little more
thoroughly.
I'm going to warn you right
now, that there's a bug in
this code, and in the next
lecture, we'll see if we can
discover what that is.
So, it takes two arguments; x,
the number whose square root
we're looking for,
and epsilon, how
close we need to get.
It assumes that x is
non-negative, and that epsilon
is greater than zero.
Why do we need to assume
that's epsilon is
greater than zero?
Well, if you made epsilon zero,
and then say, we're
looking for the square root
of two, we know we'll
never get an answer.
So, we want it to be positive,
and then it returns y such
that y times y is within
epsilon of x.
It's near, to use the
terminology we used before.
The next thing we see in the
program, is two assert
statements.
This is because I never trust
the people who call my
functions to do the
right thing.
Even though I said I'm going to
assume certain things about
x and epsilon, I'm actually
going to test it.
And so, I'm going to assert
that x is greater than or
equal to zero, and that epsilon
is greater than zero.
What assert does, is it tests
the predicate, say x greater
than or equal to zero, if it's
true, it does nothing, just
goes on to the next statement.
But if it's false, it prints a
message, the string, which is
my second argument here, and
then the program just stops.
So rather than my function going
off and doing something
bizarre, for example running
forever, it just stops with a
message saying, you called me
with arguments you shouldn't
have called me with.
All right, so that's the
specification and then my
check of the assumptions.
The next thing it does, is it
looks for a range such that I
believe I am assured that my
answer lies between the ran--
these values, and I'm going to
say, well, my answer will be
no smaller than zero, and
no bigger than x.
Now, is this the tightest
possible range?
Maybe not, but I'm not
too fussy about that.
I'm just trying to make sure
that I cover the space.
Then I'll start with a guess,
and again I'm not going to
worry too much about the guess,
I'm going to take low
plus high and divide by two,
that is to say, choose
something in the middle of
this space, and then
essentially do what
we've got here.
So it's a little bit more
involved here, I'm going to
set my counter to one, just to
keep checking, then say, while
the absolute value of the
guess squared minus x is
greater than epsilon, that is
to say, why my guess is not
yet good enough, and the counter
is not greater than a
hundred, I'll get
the next guess.
Notice by the way, I have a
print statement here which
I've commented out, but I sort
of figured that my program
would not work correctly the
first time, and so, I, when I
first typed and put in a print
statement, it would let me see
what was happening each
iteration through this loop,
so that if it didn't work, I
could get a sense of why not.
In the next lecture, when we
look for the bug in this
program, you will see me
uncomment out that print
statement, but for now, we
go to the next thing.
And we're here, we know the
guess wasn't good enough, so I
now say, if the guess squared
was less than x, then I will
change the low bound
to be the guess.
Otherwise, I'll change the high
bound to be the guess.
So I move either the low bound
or I move the high bound,
either way I'm cutting
the search space
in half each step.
I'll get my new guess.
I'll increment my counter,
and off I go.
In the happy event that
eventually I get a good enough
guess, you'll see a--
I'll exit the loop.
When I exit the loop, I checked,
did I exit it because
I exceeded the counter,
I didn't have
a good-enough guess.
If so, I'll print the message
iteration count exceeded.
Otherwise, I'll print the
result and return it.
Now again, if I were writing a
square root function to be
used in another program, I
probably wouldn't bother
printing the result and the
number of iterations and all
of that, but again, I'm doing
that here for, because we want
to see what it's doing.
All right.
We'll run it a couple times
and then I'll let
you out for the day.
Let's go do this.
All right.
We're here.
Well, notice when I run
it, nothing happens.
Why did nothing happen?
Well, nothing happens, it
was just a function.
Functions don't do anything
until I call them.
So let's call it.
Let's call square root bi with
40.001 Took only one at--
iteration, that was pretty
fast, estimated two as an
answer, we're pretty happy
with that answer.
Let's try another example.
Let's look at nine.
I always like to, by the way,
start with questions whose
answer I know.
We'll try and get a little
bit more precise.
Well, all right.
Here it took eighteen
iterations.
Didn't actually give me the
answer three, which we know
happens to be the answer, but it
gave me something that was
within epsilon of three, so it
meets the specification, so I
should be perfectly happy.
Let's look at another example.
Try a bigger number here.
All right?
So I've looked for the square
root of a thousand, here it
took twenty-nine iterations,
we're kind of creeping up
there, gave me an estimate.
Ah, let's look at our infamous
example of two, see
what it does here.
Worked around.
Now, we can see it's actually
working, and I'm getting
answers that we believe are
good-enough answers, but we
also see that the speed of
what we talk about as
convergence-- how many
iterations it takes, the
number of iterations-- is
variable, and it seems to be
related to at least two things,
and we'll see more
about this in the
next lecture.
The size of the number whose
square root we're looking for,
and the precision to which
I want the answer.
Next lecture, we'll look at a,
what's wrong with this one,
and I would ask you to between
now and the next lecture,
think about it, see if you can
find the bug yourself, we'll
look first for the bug, and then
after that, we'll look at
a better method of finding
the answer.
Thank you.